Continue your work from the last section. If you have just opened your project, you will need to load the level named 01 Cinematics Cam Pan.
You'll also need to select and open the level sequence in anticipation of more animation work.
You'll start with a simple motion, with a camera panning in the scene, essentially moving in a straight line from point A to point B.
In the last section, you learned how to place a camera in the scene and adjust its transforms.
Sometimes, an easier way to place a camera is to adjust your perspective view, and then choose the Create Camera Here option in the Viewport menu.
You can then switch to the Camera View to fine-tune it.
For a bit of housekeeping, you can rename the camera to Cam Pan,
and place it in a new folder called Cameras.
If you scrub the animation at this stage, you'll notice it is about 1000 frames long, with a few characters animated and others posed.
The time of day is also animated, as are some lights in the scene around frame 600.
If you want to mute some of these animations, such as the time of day or solar time, you can do so with a right-click on the track.
To animate the camera, you need to add it to Sequencer. This is easily done with a click and drag from the Outliner.
It adds a camera track with the core properties that can be animated, and then adds a camera track with the same properties.
You can also add a camera track to the sequence, and then add a camera track to the sequence.
You can also add a camera track with the core properties that can be animated, such as Transforms, Aperture and Focal Length.
But it also adds a Camera Cuts track, where you can define various camera shots to be played in sequence.
The little camera icon in the camera track lets you toggle between what the camera sees and a regular view.
The same icon on the Camera Cuts track will let you view the camera shots as you define them in the track.
Currently, it is hard to see, as you only have one camera, so we'll revisit this one.
For now, let's animate the camera. At frame 0, make sure the camera is active, ensure it is in a starting spot you like and create a Transform keyframe for it.
This will simultaneously create location, rotation and scale keyframes.
We don't really need a scale keyframe, so an alternative would have been to create keyframes for location and rotation only. This will do fine though.
Scrub through to about frame 300. That's about a third of the current animation length.
Move the camera to the right by driving it, and set another Transform keyframe.
Scrub between these two keyframes to see the end results. You can also playback the animation using the playback controls.
To restrict the playback between frame 0 and 300, you can adjust the playback range.
You can define the range by dragging the green and red markers,
or by using the square brackets as specific frames. In this case, using the left bracket at frame 0,
and the right bracket at frame 300.
If you want the animation to loop, you can adjust the last icon in the playback controls accordingly.
Note the ease-in, ease-out nature of the camera pan. I actually like this, but if you prefer to fine-tune that effect, or indeed eliminate it and replace it with a linear motion, you can certainly do that.
You can select the Transform track, and open the Curve Editor to adjust the tangents.
But for a linear effect, you can simply select all keyframes and turn their interpolation to Linear.
If you don't need the power of the Curve Editor, you can make keyframe interpolation changes directly in Sequencer.
So now we have our first camera animation. Before we move on to the next, there's one last viewing mode to mention.
We talked about Cinematic View versus Array View.
There's also the option to use a Cinematic Viewport, which adds playback controls to the view.
You can also use the
You can use it in conjunction with the Camera Cuts track to view what the cameras are looking at.
The advantage of this mode is that it still gives you access to playback controls if you go full-screen using F11.
This will give you more real estate to view your camera compositions and better analyze your shots.
Save your work. In the next section, you create a dolly shot using a Rig Rail.
Thanks for watching!